bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france expliquez nous comment est ce que
vous vous assurez votre mission
aujourd'hui avec quelle voyant d'où
vient-il
bonjour merci pour l'invitation
c'est vrai que malheureusement après la
chute de kaboul il y a eu beaucoup de
promesses mais ces promesses et 16 aides
n'arrivent pas à temps on est en plein
crise humanitaire catastrophe humaine et
là les petites fillettes sont bondues
donc pas mal de province les adultes et
les adultes vendre leurs organes pour
pouvoir survivre et aussi nourrir leur
famille
aujourd'hui vous parler de 2 5 milliards
d'aidés de la part des nations unies
mais malheureusement on ne sait pas
quand est-ce que ces aides vont arriver
et qu'il ya un autre problème
la communauté internationale que ce soit
l'union européenne ou des nations unies
continuent à utiliser les mêmes méthodes
c'est à dire de travailler avec des
chefs de guerre
pendant ces dernières vingt ans ils ont
travaillé avec les moudjahidine avec
ceux qui avaient les moudjahidine qui
titille former le gouvernement et que la
corruption était et est présente partout
dans le pays des milliards et des
milliards d'argent a été dépensé pour
rien et aujourd'hui on voit que
malheureusement ils font d'énormes
erreurs la corruption est toujours
présente en afghanistan les corons plus
de membres de gouvernement d'anciens
gouvernement réussi à passer des accords
avec ce nouveau régime taliban et qu'
ils sont toujours dans le présent dans
le gouvernement afghan et les ai
malheureusement dans les provinces est
par exemple n'est les plus pauvres
d'afghanistan de province et de bamiyan
et dai kundi solomun sur 7 2 % des aides
on était acheminée jusqu'aux dans ces
provinces après il y à un autre problème
des problèmes ethniques et religieuses
dans beaucoup de provinces où sont
habités par des ces minorités ethniques
et religieuses
comme dans la provence de rôle de maidan
wardak puncheur badakhshan balle ou dans
certains districts de province de ghazni
mais malheureusement aujourd'hui tout
alors on parlait aussi je pense que les
nations unies ont demandé cet argent
pour un meilleur avenir pour le pays
mais quand on a il y a deux problèmes il
faut bien distinguer les problèmes parce
que il ya la crise humanitaire mais
aussi il ya une crise politique qui est
aussi très importante en afghanistan je
voudrais évidemment où je voudrais qu'on
reste sur cette question de l'aide
humanitaire on a donc entendu les
nations unies promettre que cette aide
versée ne tomberait pas entre eux les
mandé des talibans commence à en assurer
ce qu'il faut qu'elle soit directement
distribuée aux associations des
associations comme la vôtre par exemple
alors nous on est une association
militante malheureusement on ne peut pas
être présentes en afghanistan mais par
contre on est en contact avec beaucoup
d'associations locales on est en contact
avec beaucoup de mouvements d'opposition
qui se créent tous les jours contre les
talibans ont nié en contact on est
présent dans 22 provinces d'afghanistan
et on travaille avec le peuple afghan on
travaille avec cette nouvelle génération
qui est oublié et aujourd'hui pour nous
c'est un crime de d'oublier une grande
part de la société une part
très importante puisque cette part est
constitué de la nouvelle génération
c'est d'aider des jeunes qui sont
ils et ion qui sont très compétents qui
peuvent même avoir un rôle très
déterminant pour l'avenir d'afghanistan
et
mais malheureusement on écoute eux
obtenaient de savoir que les aujourd'hui
l'aliénation unis où la communauté
internationale l'union européenne ne
veulent pas travailler avec cette
nouvelle génération avec des
associations locales de plus en plus
vous voyez les manifestations des femmes
à kaboul aujourd'hui laisser les seuls
qui peuvent encore
manifester puisque il ya une tolérance
envers les femmes est qu'aujourd'hui ce
qu'ils demandent on est en contact
permanent avec ces mouvements
d'opposition ce qui le demandaient ce
que la communauté internationale
utilise et ses 7 7 6 de ses compétences
et ses potentiels puisque ces jeunes là
pendant ces derniers ces vingt dernières
années on étudiait et qui sont
aujourd'hui prêts à assurer le bon
acheminement des aides jusque dans les
endroits reculés d'afghanistan mais
malheureusement cette nouvelle
génération éduquée et oubliés de la part
de la communauté internationale n'est
aussi les nations unies et l'union
européenne merci beaucoup d'avoir pris
le temps de réagir sur notre antenne
rêva jafari je rappelle que vous êtes
président de l'association à enfants
d'afghanistan et d'ailleurs